this is not dipping my body but it's so
good for my everything else today us two
Americans are gonna try afternoon tea
for the first time in the heart of
London although this guy is in it
doesn't that mean that it's a worth of
video I'm not Andrew my mandrew
no I'm not oh my gosh so I couldn't tell
him are you ready to have a tea party
jairs thank you for joining us here
traditionally afternoon tea comprised of
an afternoon tea stand afternoon tea is
basically to bridge the gap between
lunch and dinner
come on it with three tiers on the
bottom eww savory sandwich tier
traditionally finger sandwiches and then
moving up you'd have a scones here
this score is traditionally clotted
cream and jam and then on the top you'd
finish with all your delicate pastries
and that also be accompanied with a cup
of tea today I'm going to be preparing
our sharp and L inspired afternoon tea
so T is just one component afternoon tea
the focus of unity traditionally it's
the whole package what is the right way
to go about this whole experience and
the pinkie yeah it is the pinky you know
pretty good
nobody's pretentious
[Laughter]
so you take your filter and then you
pour it
what is the Belgian for it catches it
seedlings traditionally you you wouldn't
use a tea back with you'd see it so it's
loosely set to make the flavor even
broader yes yeah
do you people cheers when they do their
team ever cheese with everything
beautiful it's amazing for some reason
reminds me of a dollhouse you know it's
so properly put together I don't want to
eat it so tempting as it may be to start
at the top you can fortune you have to
start the bottom and then you work your
way up through the tears from savory to
sweet and savory
it's a finish on the street we have a
selection of five different finger
sandwiches smoked salmon is quite
popular cucumber and cream cheese is
ever so popular as well we've done a
twist on the foot Samata focaccia we
have a hamon mustard there a red onion
and cream cheese and then at the back we
have beef and horseradish two finger
sandwiches at first I was worried that
these would be sandwiches made out of
fingers of different animals but it's
not yeah I was worried about that dough
okay you're telling me that thought
didn't like pop into your head for a
second when we said finger sandwiches
all right it's so easy to eat it's
almost scary I feel like I get it you've
done it 20 of these like popcorn got the
roast beef here roast beef
look I'm really rich from mayonnaise
that's really good this is cool good
these are this kind of sandwiches that I
would make at home they're very simple
there's something like nostalgic about
it like this is something my mom would
make me like going off this cool light
this experience because this makes me
feel hot
yeah a little pampering but somebody is
putting it in the easiest form where you
just put it in your mouth all right
everyone
complete oh I'm already pretty full
the middle tier is two types of scones
we have a Sicilian lemon scrub and we
have the sharpen della Walker chocolate
scone traditionally served with hot tea
cream and jam but we've done our little
spin on it and we've done vanilla
mascarpone and an orange marmalade you'd
break the scrub and when it's up to you
whether you of cream first and then jam
or jam and cream what do you do I know
there's a lot of controversy for me
you've got to put the cream on first all
over the lemon one first yeah cuz
they're already pre sliced elmo's cream
first oh my god that is thick did you
just eat without me without sharing I'm
making a sandwich a proper stoned hmm
that's really good
it's not dry at all it looks like it's
like crumbly to the point of the dry but
in your mouth with the cream cheese and
the jam it really helps solidify the
whole thing it comes together perfect
combination of flavors chopper to this
guy man I'm making a mess over yeah all
right it looks like egg yolk cheers old
bloke shiz it's so good a great tea
party this is
oh my god this is awesome
so himself we have the sugar rings with
the chocolate sauce we have a tiramisu
we have the smallest chocolate cake you
go to the electric and then we have some
melon that it's a powdered doughnut and
you dip it in chocolate oh my god
don't that looks so good look at that
Cheers layer hell whatever it is we wish
we are in our spin
you know how I know it's so wrong
because it tastes so good Cheers
mmm mmm the crumpet this must be the oh
no brownie oh it's a laminating boil the
chocolate top oh my god
go big or go home let the rain flow whoa
dude I always pictured afternoon tea as
like this very light sophisticated like
we're going to have over here oh that's
a unique flavor right there it's not
just straight-up chocolate I was like a
lemon or something in there it's really
good look I'm dead we did it we had
afternoon tea we did I feel like we are
in the British version of Sex in the
City right now I don't know what those
people do in that show but they're
always hanging out at cafes at 2:00 p.m.
how people do this in between lunch and
dinner commonly is beyond me I did enjoy
it it was a good time I did too
you know it's exciting you get such a
variety of things you get to go on a
little adventure with your friend while
you hang out
[Music]